QUESTION.
WHEN YOU ORDER STARBUCKS HOW DO
YOU LIKE IT, GRANDE, VENTI,
DOUBLE SHOT OF AWKWARD
CONVERSATION.
>> STARBUCK'S NEW CAMPAIGN IT'S
CALL RACE TOGETHER.
YOU GET A CUP OF COFFEE AND THEY
WRITE HASHTAG "RACE TOGETHER."
THEY WANT THEIR BARISTAS TO
ENGAGE IN THEIR CUSTOMERS IN
THIS BIGGER CONVERSATION ABOUT
RACE.
>> HOLD ON STARBUCKS, YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT RACE.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO ON THE NIGHTLY
SHOW.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU GETTING IN MY BUSINESS I'M
GETTING IN YOURS, ALL RIGHT.
HERE, HOW DO YOU LIKE THAT.
MAKING SOME COFFEE RIGHT HERE.
COME ON, COFFEE.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S GOING TO BE THERE
STARBUCKS, ALL RIGHT.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW, YOU'RE LOSING A
DOLLAR A SECOND RIGHT NOW,
RIGHT.
LOOKS LIKE SOMEBODY'S GOING TO
HAVE TO EXPLAIN RACE AND PROFIT
LOSSES TO THEIR SHAREHOLDERS,
ALL RIGHT.
SERIOUSLY, DO WE REALLY EXPECT
SOME POOR BARISTA TO HANDLE A
CONVERSATION ON RACIAL POLITICS?
THAT'S A LOT OF PRESSURE.
WHO ARE THEY GOING TO GET,
CORNEL WEST?
[LAUGHTER]
I MEAN NO OFFENSE PROFESSOR
WEST, I KNOW YOU CAN HANDLE A
DELICATE RACE CONVERSATION BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN HANDLE THE
DELICATE INS AND OUTS OF MY QUAD
GRANDE NON-FAT EXTRA HOT CARMEL
UPSIDE DOWN MACCHIATO.
WHICH I JUST MADE. SUCK ON THAT,
STARBUCKS.
TURNING NOW TO OUR TOP STORY
TONIGHT.
WE'VE GOT TO TALK ABOUT THAT
JESUS JET.
>> I TOOK A BLOOD SWORN OATH.
THIS ATLANTA BASED MEGA
CHURCH IN THE FIRING LINE AFTER
URGING ITS MEMBERS TO FUND A
NEW GULFSTREAM JET FOR ITS
CONTROVERSIAL LEADER, PASTOR
CREFLO DOLLAR.
[LAUGHTER]
>> A NEW JET, I DON'T KNOW IF I
SHOULD BE MORE SHOCKED AT A NEW
JET OR THAT HIS NAME IS CREFLO
DOLLAR.
I MEAN, SERIOUSLY.
IT JUST SEEMS SO ON THE NOSE,
YOU KNOW.
IT WOULD BE LIKE A SERIAL KILLER
WAS NAMED JACK KNIFE.
OR A BANK ROBBER NAMED PHILIP Z.
BAG. OR A NAME YOU GUYS COME UP
WITH, SO TWEET YOUR SUGGESTIONS
WITH THE HASHTAG ON THE NOSE
NAME.
BUT LETS GET BACK TO THAT JESUS
JET.
>> CREFLO DOLLAR CREATED
THIS PROJECT ASKING
200,000 PEOPLE TO DONATE $300 OR
MORE.
THE JET DOLLAR WAS SEEKING WAS
A GULFSTREAM G650 WHICH
HAS A PRICE TAG OF $65 MILLION.
BLOOMBERG DESCRIBES IT AS THE
HOLY GRAIL OF JETS.
[LAUGHTER]
$65 MILLION?
FOR $65 MILLION YOU COULD BUY
THE JETS.
YOU WOULD BE OVERPAYING FOR THAT
TOO, MIND YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT EXACTLY IS THE MESSAGE
CREFLO DOLLAR WANTS TO SPREAD
WHILE CAREENING THROUGH THE
SKIES IN HIS PRIVATE JET.
>> DOLLAR IS FAMOUS FOR HIS
SO-CALLED PROSPERITY GOSPEL
CLAIMING RICHES WILL COME TO
THOSE WHO DONATE TO THE CHURCH.
>> Larry: PROSPERITY GOSPEL?
DAMN, GOODBYE FIRE AND BRIMSTONE
HELLO DOLCE AND GABBANA
IT SEEMS LIKE THIS MESSAGE MIGHT
BE CATCHING ON BUT NOT
EVERYBODY'S A CONVERT.
TAKE US TO SUNDAY SCHOOL NOTED
RELIGIOUS SCHOLAR REZA ASLAN
>> THE FASTEST GROWING
PROTESTANT MOVEMENT IN NORTH
AMERICA IS THE MOVEMENT REFERRED
TO AS THE POSTERITY GOSPEL.
THE ARGUMENT OF THE PROSPERITY
GOSPEL IF I CAN PUT IT
FLIPPANTLY IS THAT JESUS WANTS
YOU TO DRIVE A BENTLEY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I FEEL THE POWER OF THE V8. I'M
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE DRINK.
I'M TALKING ABOUT 400 HEAVENLY
HORSES PULLING ME
ON THE THIRD DAY WHEN SOMETHING
WASN'T DELIVERED, I AIN'T
TALKING ABOUT THAT. WHO SAID
MERCEDES?
GET THAT DEVIL OUT OF HERE,
HERE'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
CAN I HAVE AN AMEN FOR
A BENTLEY
>> AMEN.
>> I SAID CAN I HAVE AN AMEN FOR
A BENTLEY.
>> AMEN.
>> CAN I GET A RIDE TO THE STORE
BECAUSE I WASN'T ABLE TO MAKE
THE PAYMENTS FOR MY BENTLEY.
NOW LOOK I KNOW YOU'RE THINKING
BENTLEY PRIVATE PLANES.
HOW MUCH DO THESE JETSETTING
PROPHETS OF PROFIT MARGINS MAKE
ANYWAY. LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
CREFLO IS AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
LIST AND IT MAY BE DUE TO THE
FACT HE'S ONLY ASKING FOR MONEY.
SOME OF THESE PREACHERS WORK
HARD FOR THE MONEY.
TAKE IT, TAKE IT.
TAKE IT.
[LAUGHTER]
WAIT.
DOES HE HAVE THE FORCE?
TAKE IT, TAKE IT.
THAT IS THE WORST.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN SUCH HORRIBLE.
[LAUGHTER]
I MEAN HE'S AWESOME, HE'S
AWESOME.
OH MY GOD
THESE GUYS ARE THE MODERN DAY
SNAKE OIL SALESMEN
I WANTED TO TALK TO AN EXPERT SO
PLEASE WELCOME OUR LORD AND
SAVIOR JESUS CHRIST.
[CROWD CHEERING]
WELCOME TO THE SHOW JESUS.
>> THANK YOU.
THAT'S VERY NICE.
>> VERY SYMBOLIC, I DON'T WANT
TO LOSE THAT.
>> YES.
BLESSED TO BE HERE LARRY, THANK
YOU.
>> NO PROBLEM.
NOW JESUS WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THE PROSPERITY GOSPEL AND
THESE MONEY-LOVING CREATURES
LIKE THIS ONE ATLANTA ASKING
EVERYONE TO BUY HIM A
LUXURY JET.
I WANT YOUR TAKE ON THIS.
>> OH, THAT'S A LOVELY WINE.
NICE WINE.
>> WE PUT WATER IN THERE.
>> I MEAN LARRY.
>> I MADE COFFEE EARLIER.
NOT THE SAME, NOT THE SAME.
ALL RIGHT. I WASN'T TRYING TO
MAKE US EQUAL
SO WHAT ABOUT THESE PREACHERS.
>> I DON'T PAY ATTENTION TO
THOSE GUYS.
IT'S A BIG WORLD LARRY, LOTS OF
STUFF HAPPENING ALL OVER.
OH, I'M SORRY, THAT'S ME.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW YOU TEXTED.
YOU MUST GET SOME PRETTY
IMPORTANT TEXTS.
>> THAT WAS JUST AN UPDATE ON
THE SYRIAN REFUGEES.
LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE STILL
REFUGEE-ING.
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT A LUXURY
JET, WAS IT?
>> YES.
NOW THESE PREACHERS WHO USE
YOUR NAME TO SQUEEZE MONEY OUT
OF POOR PEOPLE I THINK IT'S
HORRIBLE.
>> POOR PEOPLE LARRY OR POOR
AMERICANS.
OH, I'M SORRY.
I HAVE A GOOGLE ALERT FOR
POVERTY.
DID YOU KNOW 850 MILLION PEOPLE
ARE HUNGRY OR STARVING RIGHT
NOW?
>> I DID NOT KNOW THAT.
>> LET'S FOCUS ON THE POOR
PEOPLE YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT,
LARRY, SORRY.
>> I WOULDN'T CHARACTERIZE IT
LIKE THAT.
I WAS JUST TRYING TO MAKE A
POINT.
>> I DO HAVE THIS TAKE THIS,
SORRY.
HELLO, DAD.
HI.
YOU KNOW I HEARD ABOUT THE MUD
SLIDE.
HOW MANY ARE MISSING.
OH JESUS.
I MEAN, OH ME, WHAT AM I
THINKING.
I'M ON IT.
AS SOON AS I'M DONE HERE.
THE NIGHTLY SHOW WITH LARRY
WILMORE.
[LAUGHTER]
NO, NOT HIM.
HE LEFT.
HE'S TAKING OVER FOR LETTERMAN
I'VE GOT TO GO DAD, I'M SORRY.
I'VE GOT TO GO.
I'M SORRY, LARRY.
>> DOES HE KNOW WHO'S TAKING
OVER FOR JON?
DON'T GO THERE.
I THOUGHT I'D ASK.
YOU NEVER KNOW.
[APPLAUSE]
I KNOW YOU'RE BUSY BUT I JUST
WANTED TO KNOW ARE PEOPLE LIKE
CREFLO DOLLAR TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF POOR PEOPLE.
>> YES, OF COURSE THEY ARE.
BUT DON'T WORRY ME AND POPS WILL
GET THEM ON THE BACK END.
>> I GOT YOU.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
>> ANYTHING ELSE LARRY WHILE I'M
HERE?
>> WHAT SHOULD WE BE DOING ABOUT
GLOBAL WARMING.
>> NO NO, THAT ONE'S ON YOU
GUYS.
LOOK, I'LL GIVE YOU A HINT.
IX-NAY ON ABORTIONS AND GAY
MARRIAGE.
I'VE GOT TO ROLL.
JESUS OUT, GOOD-BYE.
>> JESUS, EVERYBODY.